[Music]
big night in the state of georgia two
senate races there of course we've been
telling you both are too close to call
at this hour numbers coming in as we
await the conclusion
let's reflect on this there was a point
in american history and many people
regarded carl bernstein
as an actual journalist he was part of
the watergate scandal
back in the early 70s brought to you by
the washington post
that was a story that unseated the
president who won the single largest
landslide in american history
but he had to leave office because of it
no one remembers the details but it was
a big deal
the weird thing is carl bernstein
doesn't seem to think watergate was that
big a deal
in fact carl bernstein has devoted his
entire professional career to
downplaying the watergate
story what's bigger than watergate you
might ask
according to carl bernstein pretty much
everything's bigger than watergate
so this in some ways is worse than
watergate
this is something far worse than
occurred in watergate
this is very different than watergate
and more dangerous in many ways
this could be worse than watergate i've
said before that what we're seeing
uh is worse than watergate so that's the
first
big difference of why this is worse than
watergate
i think this is a potentially more
dangerous situation than watergate what
we are watching in the trump presidency
is worse than watergate
you know what that was it was worse than
watergate
but it does answer a question that's
been bothering a lot of us
for a long time why would cnn put carl
bernstein
on tv i mean seriously and the answer of
course
is precisely that so he can say it's
worse than watergate
the mystery of carl bernstein's
contributor contract solved tonight
breaking news